daylight saving time people still debate
why we do it
and I'm happy to chalk it up as just one
of those mysteries of the universe it's
just that you know the Sun doesn't care
what time you call it the plants don't
care and here we are with more sunlight
at the end of the day and then the days
get shorter daylight time gets shorter
and just when you want more sunlight we
take away the daylight saving time in
the winter don't you want that extra
hour when you have less hours of light
at the end of the day so that's a bit of
a mystery to me I don't really
understand it and in Arizona they have
enough Sun no one said we need more Sun
so Arizona just didn't know there is no
last I checked no daylight saving time
in Arizona so it's certainly not an
Astrophysical decision to create
daylight saving time especially since we
create our own light in Ben Franklin's
day they had like gas lamps maybe not
even that just oil lamps so we're no
longer so slaved to the rhythms of the
Sun and Moon that the Sun and Moon they
no longer need to matter to us as we
schedule our day and it seems to me
we've outlived the usefulness of
daylight saving time